What's up wise,
crack jared,
eternally trapped in your computer here.
Self-Aware humor is all around us.
Deadpool cabin in the woods and even
galaxy quest are all well loved and it's
easy to see why they make fun of the
very genres they inhabit and they're all
part of a growing trend of media that
makes fun of well itself be a superhero.
Listen,
the day I decided to become a crime
fighting swindler who rooms with a bunch
of other little whiners at the Neverland
mansion of some creepy old bald heaven's
gate looking mother.
On that day,
I'll send your shiny happy as a friend
request
and since this trend isn't going away
anytime soon,
we thought we'd give you a little primer
on the complex nature of self criticism.
So in order to gain elevated insight on
how we get on the world around us,
let's explore the ever so important
distinction between satire and parody.
Both satire and parody exists to
criticize the world and hey,
that's like my number one favorite thing
to do,
but like all things,
there's a lot of bad satire and bad
parody today.
We're going to figure out the heart of
what each is with two wisecrack,
crack,
faves,
watchman,
and one punch man.
So join us as we dive deep into the
nuances of their respective genres so
that we can appreciate these amazing
properties,
even more.
This wisecrack condition on parody and
satire with watchman and one punch man.
And as always,
spoilers ahead and we'll be using images
from the watchman movie and the graphic
novel.
So please don't freak out.
But before we get into it,
want to give a quick shout out to
alliance heroes of the spire who enabled
us to make this video today.
Alliance heroes are the spire,
combines the best RPG elements,
create a classic game that actually puts
your skills to the test.
Unlike other mobile games,
you actually got to work for your winds
here.
People,
real time Pvp,
crazy bosses,
and an insanely high number of hero
combinations.
Make this the game to play during work.
No,
not that I do that.
Plus you get the rec tons of bosses,
just like an anime.
Click on the link below to download the
game for free and you'll also get 50,000
gold and 50 gems on the house.
Have you ever owned that much gold in
your life?
I sure haven't.
Thanks again to alliance here is with
the spire and now back to your regularly
scheduled geek out.
Let's start with a refresher course in
alphabetical order.
One Punch man follows cytoma a hero
capable of defeating any enemy in a
single punch.
On the flip side,
we've got watchman,
a story that asks the question,
what if superheroes were just people
like us?
Which is to say,
before we get into categorizing,
let's talk about what these stories have
in common.
Most clear is their willingness to take
the archetypes of their respective
genres and twist them around.
One Punch man takes an animate trope
like magical girls.
I'll off sailor moon and distorts it
with a swole ex convict.
There's also the familiar hardworking
every man hero,
but he's just a De buffed version of
Toku hero common writer.
And of course we have a Goku s world's
savior,
but he looks like a low rent Halloween
costume attached to an egg.
On the watchman side,
we've got an army of Superhero
knockoffs.
Both roar shack and Ozymandias are
distillations of certain elements of
Batman.
Ozymandias says the charismatic,
rich and hyper intelligent Bruce Wayne.
The force of good that the world needs
clean cuts and above the fray.
Roar Shack,
on the other hand,
is the detective Batman fighting crime
and searching for truth with a capital
t,
much like the world's greatest detective
[inaudible] shacks,
quest for truth and justice fears
dangerously close to a horrifying
obsession.
He's like the ugly version of Frank
Miller's take on the Cape Crusader and
for good measure,
there's night owl,
a recreation of the nerdy inventor
version of Batman,
Allah,
Adam West,
and his shark repellent.
Both stories use these twisted up
versions of recognizable characters to
make observations about what we take for
granted and supercrew stories.
The types of heroes we see,
what we expect them to do,
and what we think motivates them to
shoot.
Oh,
you know,
10 of them done by changing up what
we're used to.
The departure from the original tropes
sticks out like a sore thumb.
In both stories,
this contrast explores what we'll call a
more realistic version of superhero
power.
What is having God like power really
like to find out?
Let's turn to a pair of hairless wonders
site Toma and Doctor Manhattan.
While a pair of galactically powerful
heroes isn't exactly the kind of thing
you'd see in real life,
they're reaction to power very much is
both Cytoma and doctor Manhattan
confront the boredom afforded by
omnipotence site to must spends his time
mourning his lack of a true challenge.
While doctor Manhattan mostly has weird
sex,
hangs out on Mars and contemplates the
nature of time despite their vast power,
neither is a traditional protagonist
like that man or Goku because neither
one struggles in a traditional way.
While Goku has to train with King Kai
and sprint along passages between
worlds.
Cytoma just does some pushups.
Batman puts together clues to solve
mysteries.
Doctor Manhattan literally knows
everything and Community Jack
wants me to look into my future.
See if the colors that were publicly
identified,
where do you see the stories about good
guys overcoming the odds,
but for site and doctor Manhattan,
physical confrontations are over before
they start.
Doctor Manhattan one the Vietnam War by
himself and cite them up,
beat up an alien that searched entire
galaxies for a worthy adversary without
ever even giving it his full effort.
Well done.
[inaudible] Motor,
the hung a tote on Oca.
So what is the one critical difference
between the method of one punch man and
watchman?
Watchman is a satire and one punch man
is a parody.
While one is ultimately an adoration of
the genre,
it lovingly pokes fun at the other is a
burn it all approach.
So the heroes who used to cover our
jammies according to satire,
a critical reintroduction by Dustin
Griffin,
org of is designed to attack vice or
folly.
It seeks to persuade an audience that
something or someone is reprehensible or
ridiculous.
When it takes over another literary
structure,
it tends not to just borrow it,
but to subvert it or direct its energies
toward alien ends.
Watchmen as a satire doesn't just attack
the vices and follow these up society
and the superhero genre.
It's specifically assaults,
the idea of anyone possessing powers
that even approach that of a nuclear
weapon.
It's largely about nuclear fear only
this time,
it's not just directed at a bomb,
but a blue skinned super being John
Osterman becomes doctor Manhattan in a
nuclear accident,
ease then recruited and used as a weapon
to win the Vietnam War.
Even his name is eight far from subtle
reference to the Manhattan project.
He's fascinated by both time and clocks
and throughout watchman.
We often see clocks counting down toward
undesirable outcomes.
In the graphic novel,
this is even clearer.
Nuclear security is referenced all the
time and fear of nukes drives many kinds
of conflict.
The Vietnam War was a response to fear
of nuke wielding Russians,
riots and violence on the home front in
opposition to superheroes all returned
to the fear of a nuclear threat
symbolized by blue skin space wizard,
doctor Manhattan,
the Ussr and USA need a fabricated
attack on earth to even set aside their
differences,
exposing the extreme lengths taken and
casualties sustained just to de escalate
the nuclear standoff.
Watchman shows the dangers of power,
but also it's indifference.
Doctor Manhattan gets bored of
everything and in his boredom becomes
increasingly conflicted about the nature
of existence.
I prefer this.
Don't let here
[inaudible]
I am tired of earth.
He's people.
I'm tired of being caught in the tangle
of their lives.
It's ultimately a grim joke about
superman.
If he were really an all powerful being,
why would he worry about humanity?
In my opinion,
the existence of life is a highly over
right.
This phenomenon,
it's even clear in his sartorial
choices.
Superman rocks his costume to evoke the
American values of truth,
justice,
and the American way.
While doctor Manhattan strips himself of
ideology and gets naked,
watchmen makes a more explicit point
about the corrupting influence of power
with the comedian.
Superhero stories ask us to believe that
the good guys with power are the ones
who deserve it,
but watchman is more than willing to
point out that they're not.
The comedian is a hero in the mold of
Captain America or Wolverine and extra
strong,
intelligent,
hyper capable super soldier,
but he's also a sadist psychopath.
Watchman isn't just making these
observations to satisfy your brain's
thinky parts.
It uses the form of the superhero genre
like Batman clones and all powerful
beings and the content of the story,
the try and persuade an audience,
but persuade them of what you might ask.
Well,
there's certainly the problem of nukes,
but Griffin also says that satire wants
to prove that something or someone is
reprehensible or ridiculous,
and in this case,
that's something is the very idea of
superheroes.
Watchman is dedicated to making the case
that the very existence of superheroes
is a dangerous fantasy.
You can compare it to a classic work of
satire.
Jonathan Swift's a modest proposal where
the author suggests solving famine by
eating children,
of course,
which wasn't actually pro kid eating.
He was just trying to show the failure
of society in his time and did so by
inhabiting the form of a political essay
that overtly exhibits the indifference
to suffering,
that characterize those in power.
Just as swift use the form of a
political essay to make the people who
write to political essays look like
heartless monsters.
Watchmen uses the form of a superhero
narrative to make superheroes look
dangerous and it posits that superheroes
create an asymmetry of power that defies
regulations.
Superheros can violate the rules and
commit acts of violence at their own
discretion,
even if they have everybody's best
interests at heart.
That degree of power inevitably becomes
dangerous as different ethical frames
allow roar shack and Ozzie Mandy has
come into conflict,
whether it be super powers or nuclear
powers,
that degree of power will inevitably
lead to some ups.
Watchman can make these arguments so
effectively because it uses the
structure of superhero stories to make
its argument.
Like Griffin says,
when it takes over another literary
structure,
it tends not just to borrow it,
but to subvert it and direct its
energies toward alien ends.
Every inch of watchman is dedicated to
turning the traits we love about
superheros against themselves.
And the end of the day,
watchman condemned superhero fiction as
a genre because it promotes a dangerous
fantasy.
But site to mum might want a word about
that.
There's no doubt that one punch man is
poking fun at superheroes of both Manga
and western comics as well as the genres
themselves.
The villains in one punch man,
give intentionally over the top versions
of classic villain monologue.
No,
no.
We beat up on them.
But to know,
I mean that will pull the hallway on the
wheel.
Somebody [inaudible] you say
[inaudible] [inaudible] every
character has a dramatic backstory.
Coy got cool.
What ain't no causal connection and a
fighting spirit.
It uses anime and Manga tropes like
ocean creatures,
swarms of people in suits,
hydro style monsters and more.
It's always in conversation with other
works in the same genre,
but without the judgment we see in
watchman.
Why?
Because one punch man isn't a satire.
It's a parody.
Now let's investigate the difference and
I promise it's more than just semantics.
We've already seen how satire has a
specific persuasive function usually in
opposition to something,
but parody isn't quite like that.
Parody exaggerate certain elements of
its target,
but it ultimately affirms the literary
form it in habits to be more specific.
Worsening to Robert videon and his essay
are parody and deconstruction secretly
the same thing.
Parody excepts the logic and rules of
its genre and takes them seriously as
tools of its criticism.
As Finian says,
it operates from inside of the texts and
ideas it criticizes.
Think of how Genoese mirrors a classic
animate protagonist.
He suffered a trauma and is trying to
become strong enough to get revenge for
the people he loves,
but at every turn he's rendered a joke
by site.
Tim has immense power that doesn't
diminish Genoese.
His appeal,
we can still relate to his desires and
they aren't treated as stupid.
They're just irrelevant because cytoma
has thrown all the rules out of whack.
All the things we mentioned before,
the tropes references,
even the structures of character arcs
and stories are all classic Monga.
There's no doubt one punch man's
creators truly love the genre,
but don't think it's above ridicule.
The show makes this argument by
exaggerating the overpowered hero
archetype in many Manga anime and even
western comics,
no matter how powerful the villain gets,
the hero gets stronger to match.
Take Goku for instance,
enemies get stronger and stronger,
but Goku is always able to save the day.
Usually through some intense training
regimen.
Dragonball z celebrates this,
but one punch man asks why there are you
and other characters.
Jenn Osen,
Moomin writer,
much like crillon or Yom Tra train hard
to match their stronger friend,
but they never can and honestly don't
need to.
The real hero will always be there to
save the day by turning anime and Manga
on their heads to make these points.
One Punch man is critiquing superhero
stories by showing precisely where they
double and collapse for a great example
of where the lessons of superhero
stories collapse.
Let's get back to Moomin writer.
He has a classic backstory and grows
motivation.
Well,
mind you touch him.
He just wants to help people and be like
the heroes.
He looks up to Suny choosen.
He knew God,
not unlike Memoria for my hero academia
and much like Muh Doria before he gets
his powers.
Moomin writer constantly gets his ass
kicked.
It's a message about real life.
Some people just don't have what it
takes to be a superhero and telling
everyone they can might get them
seriously hurt.
We can see the same intrusion of reality
and Cytoma.
Most superhero stories end with the
hero.
Happy to be saving the world and waiting
for the next challenge.
Site to Ma has a more relatable
reaction.
Boredom,
there's nothing to overcome and that
leaves you without a reason to get out
of the bathtub.
This may sound like the satire rules so
far,
but instead of trying to show something
as reprehensible or ridiculous,
the crucial point for parody is that the
body of words is always pre loved and
redirected.
Parody is used to awaken us to the flaws
and the things we love,
but not to demolish a flawed genre like
watchmen aspires to do with superheroes.
One Punch man makes clear it's mocking,
animate to help expand the possibilities
of what it can do.
It's a complicated relationship mocking
the things you love.
It can be hard to tell how to approach a
parotic text,
but according to fit in,
if we read parody straight as sincere
expression without relating it to a
structure of criticism,
we misunderstand it.
That's the key.
Parody is a tool for criticism,
but that criticism operates on the
assumption that the genre it's
criticizing is worth improving.
One Punch man calls on us to get away
from the bigger monster,
bigger gun and find other stories to
tell stories about chefs,
ice skaters,
and even Mahjong players opening up the
possibilities of anime.
Storytelling is a noble goal and one
that is sorely needed.
The ending of the show amounts to
criticism of the dragon ball z model of
storytelling.
Much like Goku.
Boreaus is constantly seeking the
strongest opponents in the universe,
but unlike our say in hero,
he's willing to destroy innocence to
find the ones he wants at the same time
site to match the actual strongest being
his board of all the power one punch man
is displaying both ways.
This infinite power model can fail.
Now,
it's important to remember that one
punch man may criticize a certain kind
of superhero narrative,
but it doesn't disavow the value of
heroes.
The show wants us to recognize and
emulate the bravery we see from Genoese
and Moomin writer,
but also recognize the silliness of the
story.
We find those lessons in.
That's the critical difference between
one punch man and watchman.
Both use,
they're overpowered characters to make
points about the genre they inhabit,
but watchman makes condemnations of all
sorts of social systems beyond the
context of superheroes and even
condemned the superhero genre itself.
One Punch man feels different.
There's a general agreement that the
stories we've told forever need a little
refresh,
but that doesn't mean abandoning them
completely.
With that in mind,
we can label things like Chemo America,
Dr Strangelove,
and heather's as satire alongside
watchman and Deadpool,
galaxy quest and blazing saddles as
parody alongside one punch man.
And the Big Bang theory is none of these
things because that show,
and as always,
thanks for watching guys.
Nice.